Okay. Hey, what's going on it's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Monday morning pod
no it isn't it's time for the Thursday
afternoon. Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast and ahhh
I'm just checking in on you.
Come. I can't fucking hear myself.
What am I going to plug this in right
here? Can I hear myself? There we go.
Now I can hear myself. You
know Katie and myself, it's,
I go,
I was talking with about,
with Dean del Ray last night
outside of the comedy store.
He was talking to me about how
you know,
you know in Quinn's singers
get old. They can't, you know,
they can't sing the way
they used to, right. Jesus,
this is going to be a long way.
You know,
like I was watching Christopher
Cross last night, you know my wife,
I came home and it was cranking,
you know,
sailing, sailing away.
Go away to, well no,
the boat,
whatever the fuck he says,
cause that rat rack the whale.
Right manner do we might
listen to that shit.
[inaudible] such a lower walk.
Right.
Shit. So she was sitting
there talking. Ah,
fuck it. I'll just keep going
on this thing and I'll get
back to Dana, no matter.
She kept talking about, she goes, what
kind of like fucking music is this?
She's like, is this like
sort of uh, you know,
she was saying it was sorta disc
away. I'm like, there really isn't.
It's sort of post disco. What'd
you call that? Adult contemporary,
you know,
cuzzo raw nuts
because I ran man I like to wear
and then girls would go to low world
and there was have like the
fucking like really like, uh,
like the session musicians
they like so good. It's,
it just doesn't sound like
it's even alive. I know, it's
weird. I liked the music,
but just some of the shit, like the
drummer was amazing on those fucking,
it's just too slick, you know? I Dunno
what the fuck it is. But anyways,
I was talking to Dean and
m we were talking about,
I hate when people like bitch,
when a singer gets old and then he can't
sing the way used to and it's just like,
well,
yeah,
because back in the day they used to
sing like Robert blankets a ton of shit.
It's like,
dude,
you go sing the fucking immigrant song
every night for fucking a two year tour.
You, you're done. Right?
If you watched it.
But it might not saying he can't sing now,
but I mean,
what do you want from the guy?
He's out there drinking boozy smoking
cigarettes and he's fucking singing every
goddamn night as opposed to these modern
day people who learn from the other
guys the same way.
No drummer drives a Rolls Royce
into a swimming pool anymore. Right?
Did I almost say swimming
pool? Swimming Pool, right.
Nobody drowns in their own vomit anymore.
It happens every once in awhile.
It fucking happens. But you know, you'll
learn. It's like when I came in, um,
when I came into this business,
I saw a bunch of comics from the 80s
that didn't pay. And, and fucking
senate all up their nose and they had
their wages garnished and it was like they
were on punishment for like 10 years.
So my,
my wave of comics,
you know,
stayed away from the blow when
the booze and that type of shit.
And then what was funny,
I got about 15 years into this shit and
I noticed that people started partying
again. You know, just cause I,
they probably looked at us like we were
sitting there like we were part of the
Osman family,
you know.
So then another thing that they say
is all wowed. You see so and so man,
he got old. Oh Wow. She got old. And that
always bugs me. So say, well what do,
what the fuck happened to you? You're
not losing your looks. They look at that.
You say that enough. And now look
at all these fucking celebrities.
So walking around,
they get in their fucking lips
inflated to get net Goddamn Botox,
you know,
inject it in their face so they can be
like laminated had that nice shiny face
because nothing says youth, like
a shiny unmoving face. Right.
I don't know. I don't know how
the hell I got into that. Um,
I am going to go see a, a, I'm going
to go to a rock concert tomorrow night.
I'm going to UNMUTE, I don't even know
what the kids call them nowadays. Um,
I'm going to go see mute math tomorrow
night. Very excited about that. Um,
it makes me feel like I'm somewhat not
an old guy to be going to this thing.
And a,
I'm so old,
I can't even like classify what
their music is because uh, I had,
I was hanging with Dean last night,
a couple of other people,
couple other oldies like myself.
We were all just coming to the
realization that rock music is, it's dead.
It's just, it's dead and there's
nothing we could do. And it's, you know,
it's not coming back.
And if somebody tries to bring it back,
there'll be considered retro. Right.
Am I out of my fucking mind? But it's,
it's over. So last time you
saw somebody playing a guitar,
I don't mean some Flamenco fucking shit
or doing your acoustic version of a,
of a rap song. I don't fucking mean
that. I mean like just somebody, uh,
I dunno. I know there's a lot of people
scratching their heads going, well,
what about all that death metal and all
that shit? I of course, I'm, I'm not,
I'm not talking about that.
I'm not talking about any,
anything I've just talking about.
Basically,
I'm just an old man wondering where the
hair metal went 30 years after it died.
36 years, maybe after it fucking died.
I'm just an old man rambling on a podcast.
Don't judge me. Huh? What about you?
What are you doing right now?
You sit in a traffic, right?
You're a little fucking car.
Drive over a puddle and the fucking
water comes up through the floorboards.
You're judging me. You
take, I haven't been there.
I'm fucking with you. Um, so last
night the show is Dean del Ray.
Just a sick fucking show.
I'm Dave Attell popped in who wants again,
every time I see that guy
performed, stand up, it's just,
I talked to Bart Nick as like, as
ever not going to be the best. Um,
and there's no way for me to say what
he says or I'll say burn his jokes.
But he was just like,
he's one of those guys that he has me
dying laughing and half to half a set.
I mean the dying laughing or I'm just
standing there just, just watching them,
just shaking my head like, how the fuck
do you come up with that stuff? Um,
so what am, I guess what
I'm saying here is, um,
I like Christopher Cross and if you
have a chance, go see David. Tell,
I think that that was the purpose
of the first six minutes, right?
Is that what it is? I'm
not Jesus Christ. Oh Geez.
I didn't tell you this man. Like,
um, I was traveling a lot and I was,
I was eating really poorly my last trip
there, uh, when I was in a Foxwoods,
right? Got The town early, visited,
visited a friend of mine who unfortunately
was in the hospital but is now out.
And um,
you know,
so I was eating like shit that day and
then I fucking went up to fox woods and I
ordered room service.
Then I lied to myself that I was going
to work out it on Sunday when I could've
worked out.
I went to the Yukon game with Versie
Versie hooked me up with the ticket,
the gentleman that he is,
and I went there and I ate like shit.
So, uh, you know,
you combine eating like shit and then
getting on a plane for six hours and not
drinking enough water and then
all of a sudden, you know,
the train's not coming out of the station.
So, you know, one day the train
doesn't come and it's like,
God maybe will come the next day.
It doesn't come the next day.
And then the third day, uh, you
know, I'm like, what the fuck?
The train never comes again. Then
the, uh, the station dies. So,
uh, I started thinking I got to go
to fucking, you know, I gotta go to
Wolf Stall, right. All that shit.
But then I just got all paranoid and
I was just like, you know something,
the thing about the corporations is
that they don't want to just get you,
they want to get you hooked and they
wanna head you keep coming back. So I got,
I really started thinking about
it going like, well wait a minute.
If I go down and I take this stuff,
they'll probably be something in there,
in the little pill that tells my
digestive track to just stand down.
Yeah, we don't need you anymore. Don't
worry. We got it all right. Daddy's home.
He's going to take care of everything
and then I'm going to become hooked on
these fucking pills and then I'm going
to be one of those guys you see have any
eat blueberries every morning for fucking
breakfast trying to turn his system
around. Not realizing that he's fucking
himself far cause he went, you know,
fucking himself over because he uh,
he's eating them fucking pills every day.
Right. It's going up getting
them fucking pills. Right. So
or freckles uses his brain.
It's like there's no way that Julius
Caesar had never had a problem taking a
shit. And I know that there was
no cvs pharmacy for him to go to.
So I just looked up natural,
a natural cures and woo.
I found one that worked for all freckles.
I know this is gross,
but it's a really important
thing. I went out, okay,
it's a teaspoon of olive oil and
then you squeeze some lemon in it.
You do it with the on an empty
stomach and you fucking, you know,
you do a shot of it in the morning.
And the only thing I can compare
it to as far as how well it works,
you guys ever watch gas monkey garage and
they get some old fucking car and they
haven't turned over the engine and
well, all right, so what do they do?
They take off the fucking,
the air filter housing,
all that shit and they got that shit.
They sprayed into the carburetor,
they open the butterfly and
they have it wide open. They go,
I give it a shot and the guy turns it over
here. The fuck thanks. Starts right up.
That's basically what I did,
you know,
teaspoon of olive oil and some lemon.
You do a shot of that on an empty stomach.
I mean, you, you fucking aren't good.
You're all good. You're on fucking
grease rails for the rest of the day.
I stand by it. I'm Bill
Barr and I fucking, uh,
I stand by this and I approve
of this message. Oh my God.
Just what nobody wanted.
Or at least I didn't want.
It's down to Hillary and Donald
fucking Trump on fucking believable.
How to,
how did we get here?
Yeah.
You know what?
Cause me
unbelievable. No. Who Do fucking before.
Those are going to be my two choices.
I'm not doing it. You know what I mean?
Even though I didn't agree with everything
that Bernie Sanders wanted to do, uh,
I have to vote for a guy that went outside
the usual fucking places to get his
money for his campaign. Just to fucking
encourage somebody else to do that.
And I really can't stand when people
say that that's a waste of a vote.
I don't think it is because I
think each time, each election,
a guy like that gets a little bit farther
and I actually think it's great that,
uh,
that the Democrats and Republicans,
the best that they can come up with at
this point is Hillary Clinton and fucking
Donald Trump. I mean, Jesus,
Holy Shit, this is fucking,
I don't really think there's a
lesser of two evil here. I just, it's
okay.
You have it sitting on the
last row of a plane, you know,
and they serve in the breakfast and it's
just like, all right, your choices today.
All right.
Ham and cheese omelet or a bucket
is shit with Granola, right?
You're like, ah, fucking, and they
go and you're like, oh, fuck it.
I'm going with the fucking ham and
cheese omelet. There's no choice here.
Let's see. That's not
even a choice, right.
We to have a limited selection
of the breakfasts is so we,
if when we get to you what she
want is not available at Amelia,
like I'm fucked and you just sitting
there is every row women and she just see
the go. How do you see anything? Ham and
cheese alley and a ham and cheese omelet.
Okay. And if you say ham
and cheese Omelet, you know,
every once in awhile there's some martyr
that goes here. Take the bucket of Shit.
Right. Um, and then by the
time it gets to you, you know,
they're all gone. Even her to
say, I'm sorry sir. I'm sorry man.
We don't have any more and
cheese I'm with. I understand.
I understand you're upset,
but I don't choose how many ham and
cheese omelet throw on this flight.
Well,
I'm sorry you feel that way.
Well please go to American airlines.com/
org.net and I air your grievances there
and our robot, we'll
get back to you. Right?
So then they come up to you and of
course just, you just have to go.
You're all we have left
is the bucket of shit.
Would you like that with the Granola?
The granola kind of takes the edge
off of the shit. Would that be okay?
And you still have to
sit there and be like,
yeah,
you just drag her through it even
though it's not her fault. You know,
you don't have what happened
to ham and cheese omelet.
Yeah.
You don't have any of that.
Just started curiosity.
Do you ever started the back row and work
your way to the front just to kind of
even it out? You know, you never do that.
How come you always start up front and
work your way back to that poor excuse
for a of a kitchen? Why do you
do that? You know what I mean?
So I thought that this
was all coach evidentaly.
There isn't evidentaly
is the ham and cheese.
Sarah, why are you being hostile? Nine
11 safe. The terrorists save the chairs,
fight the terrorists. Um, so anyways, uh,
how the fuck did I get into that?
What was I talking about?
I know I was talking about, Oh yeah,
the fucking, all the election is,
I got so lost in doing that. I didn't
remember when I was talking about, yeah,
that's basically what we're left with
were basically sitting on in the last row,
middle seat right next to the
bathroom on a DC nine, you know,
we can't even look out the window
and the engine is just blocking it.
And if you like me,
you heard of this story,
the one time the engine failed
on the tarmac, thank God,
but a piece of it flew through the
fuselage and into this woman's head and
killed her. That's what I
always think about. But you
know what, I also, I also do,
it's because, uh, you know,
I didn't really look it up.
Somebody just said it to me.
But last night I did look something up
because someone was trying to tell me
that some comedian actually in American
comedian went to Dubai and had a little
bit of coke in there,
fucking suitcase that they forgot about
God caught with it and got automatic 10
years. Um, and I'm just like, really?
I go walk an American comic. And
they were like, yeah, yeah, dude,
American comic guys fucked.
Nobody had a name. No nothing.
And I looked it up and for the life of me,
I can't find it.
You know what I did find was that there
was this fucking half Iranian and half
Swedish male model who got busted
with some sick amount of coke.
Somehow got a life sentence. They
didn't kill him, but they, um,
okay.
They did kind of reduce it down
to 10 years. So he's got 10 years.
So he made a rap song in jail,
like date.
Remember that Gay Shane who
was with j Lo and Puffy,
I'm going way back to the 1990s when
people still watch music videos.
Maybe it was the year 2000. Right. And uh,
what's his face used to
do a, the TV show. Oh God,
what was it called?
Carson Daly used to do that show,
the top 40 fucking videos, whatever
the fuck it was called. Um,
yeah,
during that time, right in members
shine did the fucking, he did,
he made a song over the
Rikers island phone. This guy
did the same fucking thing.
And I got to admit like,
yeah, I dunno. I, I didn't,
I didn't have sympathy for the guy, which
is weird. It's odd for me. I was just,
you know what it was cause
he was acting like Pete rose.
It was still all about him. He was like,
I didn't have any drugs in my system.
I was blah blah. It's like, yeah, but
you were going to distribute the shit.
Your Cantonese didn't give a fuck
what happened. And those people,
you're trying to make some money.
You knew what the fine was.
You rolled the dice and you fucking lost
what kind of an asshole goes
anywhere in Asia with drugs,
you're Outta your fucking mind.
You're out of your fucking mind.
You're done. It's fucking over.
They have a zero tolerance.
The only thing they do is make the drugs
and ship it over here for some fucking
reason.
That's what I don't get.
If you get caught with drugs over there
yet, completely fucked. But God damn it,
they will make some in a minute.
Right. Well I guess that's Afghanistan.
Afghanistan is kind of the wild west,
right?
Do you think the fact that we've been at
war with them for almost a decade and a
half, you'd think that I would fucking
know a little something about them.
I don't.
What do I know about those guys?
What was the number one band in
Afghanistan? You know what I mean?
I love to hear what the fuck they would
sing above. Man, that must be amazing.
You know,
just rebelling against your parents.
Are Your parents want you to take
over the fucking opium den or a,
what are they called?
The opiate farm.
Yeah.
You know, I have a dream. I don't
want to do that. I wouldn't fucking,
I don't know what I want
to do. I want to, uh,
I want to raise llamas. What are
your career? And you know what,
I'm gonna look that up right now.
Career options in Afghanistan. You know,
they got to have a Dabrye over there.
One of those Sunni fucking Suny del
high fucking school's over. You know,
just of those schools, they just have to,
you know, just give people like, yeah,
you go, anybody can get
into this. We get it.
You just want to see you went to
college. All right. Career options.
Okay.
This is probably going to put
me on a list. Afghanistan.
I went a f and then I lost my,
my nerve on. I want APH in.
It's not l a. F. G. H. A. N. Gan is Stan.
Alicia. I spelled it right. Jobs
in Afghanistan. Danger zone jobs.
Okay.
Got My skin peeled off well.
Building fucking Starbucks. Getting
your head start off. Did he do,
did he do? Sorry. All right.
Afghanistan jobs. Employment.
All right. Career options. Afghanistan
for natives.
This is still going to be us.
Space up opportunities.
Trump.
Dangerous for Indians in
Afghanistan. All right, well this,
this got us out of America.
Let's read about this.
Somebody decided not to be a
teller telemarketer, right?
Or customer service guy leaves India
and it goes into Afghanistan. Uh,
yeah.
All right. Can't even read this
person's name, but out of respect,
I'm going to spell it.
B. A. N U. C h. A N d.
A R Ben who Chander last name,
r a.
J. E. N. D. R. A. N. Jesus Christ.
If that was ever on wheel of fortune
or you bought a vall and you said a,
if you couldn't solve that,
but even then if he didn't have any
yeah.
Consonants, you'd be that idiot
trying to solve it. Outgoing. Ah,
a Ben. Oh, sorry.
Can I get a B please? Pat?
I'd like to solve it. Ben.
A Chandler or ran or Jay drought.
No,
shittiest fucking prizes ever.
On wheel of fortune.
It's always for $700 I'll
take the brass bed frame.
They always add the brass bed frame
and like a fucking grandfather clock.
It's like,
what am I fucking 90
okay.
Do you got anything from this century
for $40 I'll take the milkmaid.
Yeah,
for 17. I'll take the butter. Churner
oh, let's see. I guess, uh, what do
you, what do I have left? $7 for $7.
I'll take the teacup set.
Yeah.
Eh, I'll take a polio shot and
I'll eat the rest of it on, um,
gift certificate. Thank you. All right.
Kabul, Afghanistan, banner or GI?
Reggie,
Chandra, Jay and Indian from the
town of who I will do. All right.
This is the townies from U s I.
L.
You still lamp patty and Tamil Nadu.
Is it weird that that met made
me want to get some Indian food?
Is there anything better than garlic naan?
I Dunno.
Spent an lonely independence day on August
15th at a Sikh temple in Kabul or he
had to, had taken refuge after
his Afghan visa expired. Well,
how the fuck do you let that happen,
Mr Your Jam Hash who came to Afghanistan
on the promise of a job as a security
guard in an American military base for
$800 every month had been swindled out of
150,000 rupees or 2,300 bucks by
his employment agent in India.
I thought, oh, I'll tell
you it's filthy. You know,
after paying the money and waiting
here for three months to 28 year old,
found out that there was no job and
was left with just enough money for his
phone in his cigarette.
Oh my God.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Do People in like Asia just laugh at
American movies like our ideas of what
trouble is? Can you imagine that?
Can you imagine? Somebody just said,
hey, you want a job in Afghanistan?
And you go, yeah, I'll fucking do that.
I feel like there's a lot of American
military right now nodding their heads
like, yeah, we know what that's like.
Yeah. You get there to start with.
They promised. Absolutely. Um,
you show up,
you think you're going to be a hero and
then they tell you you got to buy your
own uniform. Um, after paying the
money way, there was no fucking job.
He's got enough money for phone and
cigarettes. Wow. Dude, that is just,
that is next level evil.
The Indian embassy in Kabul
said that as of mid August,
70 distressed Indians.
That's the way they put it.
Right.
Like posttraumatic Stress Syndrome instead
of the classic George Carlin Bit bit
shell shocked. Right. Who
was similarity? Similarity.
A banded and were sent back
to India. Oh, they sent back,
I'll thank God last year they were 160.
Oh, so I see what this evil guy goes.
He goes, well look, then we fucked them
over and then they get freaked out.
But then they just go to the embassy
and then they pay for it, you know,
fuck you on paying my taxes.
These guys will be all right.
And then they justify it right. Then they
go out and they by themselves, you know,
some shiny shoes and a car.
The Afghans,
Sikhs had given many of the Indians
refuge in their temple and Kaboodle, uh,
describe them as mostly poor folk who
had taken loans and sold off land to pay
commission to fraudulent
employment agents.
They came with the hope of earning double
the money paid for low skilled jobs in
India.
Do do you know when I landed,
landed in Dubai when I connected
there with no cocaine in my fucking
suitcase? Do you know that?
Somebody told me that, you know,
there's basically the slave
labor camps that totaled,
that built Dubai and uh,
a lot of them were people from
India and they get promised, yeah,
you come over here, you know, the, the,
the poorest of the poor. Come over here.
You're going to make like
fucking nine zillion dollars.
You're going to have a play station. And
then when you go back, you know, whatever,
you can bring your family over here
and all that, and they show up in,
the first thing they do is they
confiscate their fucking passports.
And these people just be, they can't
leave and they just become slaves.
And a, the number one cause of death
is like suicide. You know what I mean?
Controversy at the Oscars.
I want,
I want to play a plumber.
American troubles.
Um, fucking unbelievable.
Unfucking believable man. Well,
I'm glad this person got back. Jesus
Christ. Like that's the type of shit,
you know,
you remember that show arrested abroad.
I remember back in the day on the,
uh,
the LP and Anthony Program, the tragically
now gone, Opie and Anthony Program,
one of the great radio
shows of all fucking time.
I remember we were talking about that
and we were watching that are arrested
abroad,
which just makes you never want to travel
outside of the United States again.
Or WHO's kidding? Who, you know,
they made it really fucking racial.
It was just like, you're
white. Stay in the white zone.
You can go to England,
you can go to Canada,
do not go south of San Diego
or you are on your own. Right.
But at the end of the day, as much as
these people were like fucking, you know,
in jail, they always, you know,
most of them did something
extremely fucking stupid where,
you know,
the,
they went out and bought platform shoes
and hollow them out and put a bunch of
fucking,
you know,
heroin in there and a couple of baggies
of coke up their ass. And it's just like,
do you never saw midnight express?
If you can find that clip.
I remember a long time ago
we kept riffing on that.
That Irish guy would just go, you know,
when he got busted, he just, he can,
I just kept thinking, what have I done
and what he had done. You fucking,
you fucked yourself over yet.
Dope.
Okay.
I Dunno. I Dunno. How fucked up is
your life that like, that's your option
you'd like, that sounds good.
Like, I mean, thank God I,
I just out of sheer dumb fucking luck
landed in the skin I have in the country.
I mean, like I really got,
I got dealt the, you know,
a fucking and ace in a tent.
I really did. I've totally
lucked out. You know what I mean?
If somebody ever came up
to me was just like, Hey,
do you want to put some heroin in your
ass and try to make it across the border?
It's just, it's, it's an emphatic,
definite in a final answer. Answer. No,
no, I'm good. I'm fucking
good. Don't need to do that.
You know,
dude,
I would go back to having a fucking
paper like I did in the third grade right
through freshman year. To be honest with
you. I would actually do that job again,
you know, get a nice workout
in the morning. If I didn't
live in a fucking city,
I would be a paper boy in a
fucking second is fucking great.
You got up before everybody else.
It was really peaceful, quiet.
Fucking birds were chirping. Yeah,
you had to deal with the weather,
but that's what made you fucking man.
You know, you put on your pod show,
right?
You put on your thick socks,
fucking nostrils freezer
together. Oh God, it was brutal.
I never did.
Was nothing fucking better than when
back when they were actually four seasons
on the east coast when the springtime
came and you got up in the morning and you
didn't have to wear a jacket.
I cannot even describe to you how
fucking unbelievable that was.
Um,
and the same way the ominous feeling is
when it first started getting cold and
you're like, oh fuck, here
comes another one. Um,
I told you this story before and
I had this bike, this fucking,
it was basically one of those
beach bikes with white wall tires.
I was always a sucker for
fucking white walls. And I,
I sort of pointed at the
bike making fun of it.
My Dad loved it and he grew up
in the fifties, right? Oh yeah.
We got big tires, right? They had
those big fucking peewee Herman bikes.
So I bought the bike and everybody was
laughing at me. All my friends had these,
you know, pre like fucking, uh,
we're all those fucking BMX bikes.
It was pretty BMX. It was all,
everything was all about
showing the Apollo three speed.
They only have these cool bikes.
And I had this giant Fucking Pre pee
wee Herman peewee Herman fucking bike.
And I remember one time my older brother
took it and everyone was laughing and
he wrote it down the driveway as fast
as he could in the tires was so big and
thick that when he fucking locked him up,
it actually made the sound
of a car and went like, yeah.
And then everybody thought that bike was
cool and then they, they would, you know,
that's how I, I ended up fitting
in. People come all over,
look at that stupid fucking bike and
all I had to do is lock 'em up once.
And then they laughed and thought it was
called and it was all right. You know,
they look past my orange hair and my
freckles and that's the way I was 1976.
Um, anyways, yeah, I would do
that job in a fucking second.
Somewhere along the line
it became an adult's job.
And it was a combination of when,
you know,
we finally addressed the fact that
there was a sexual predators out there.
And then also the show's made,
you feel like there was one
behind every fucking tree. MMM.
So anyways,
yeah.
So that went out to fund any of the old
economy went to shit and it became an
adult's job. But anyways, let me read
the, uh, let me read the fucking,
well the hell is, let me
do the live reads. Hey. Oh,
sailing away. Come on, come on. Come over
here and sing some Christopher Cross.
Oh, I'll do the Christopher Cross
part. You do the, you do the, uh,
the, your ma, your boy that
Michael McDonald do that
part right. All right, good.
So Bri, Bri like to win. Shopped in,
it's something and now it's time for
the Michael McDonald fucking park.
[inaudible]
no, it was bad at it. Does
it got such a long way to go?
[inaudible]
the way that, wait, no. Then he goes,
uh, cause I got such a long way to go.
Goes God,
it's such a long way to go.
[inaudible]
sorry, every once in a while and has
to just be for us. Yeah, sorry. Sorry.
Christopher Cross. Right. You know,
it's a big fan of him. Jimmy Fallon.
Jimmy Fallon sat him on,
he had him on his, uh,
when he took over for Colin and then he
has the him on the tonight show. Yeah.
Oh yeah.
I can't find a,
it was mostly annoyed. Much as you
hate that you do it all the time now.
Yeah. That was the most annoying. Oh,
stop doing that. That was
a magic Johnson son, Ajay,
Ajay. And when he was talking about
him, I'm not saying he's a bad person,
but like he's just like,
are you going up?
Because people just walk around and get
excited about sunglasses and shoes and
shit. It's just like, that's
the big fucking thing.
The material. Oh, Rad. The
materialism when people are
like, yeah, I was on his lay.
Yeah.
Hello.
No, it's fun. It's like gross. Look, I
respect somebody that has style. Yeah.
Like when we watch it, come on, come
over there. The microphone. When you,
you take Chappelle show's block party,
right? Yes. Great fucking film. Yeah.
So we watched that and when a
Lauren Hill came out, right.
Oh my God. Yeah. Crazy.
Exactly. Great stuff.
But she has sit around talking
about her shoes, everything.
Then she goes out and crushes it
and syncs as fucking suck. Okay.
But for someone to just sit there,
it just sit there and talking or
it'd be excited about blazers.
It fucking sock garters and
shit. It's just, I don't know.
And then keep you like,
just like your days all we're going to go
out and go shop for five fucking hours.
I don't understand B. What? I
said I love it. Hey by the weight,
you know something I'm going to fucking,
I'm going to handle the garage. Okay.
Cause you know no, cause you
keep pooper when the whole thing,
I understand what yeah. You know
something. If it was a common error,
if was a common area, you
would be excited. Yeah.
You think I'm not interested in
having a little gym here at the House.
I think that's a great idea.
Who wouldn't want to have their own
little gym so they don't have to go out to
work out.
Okay. Now did you guys hear what she just
said? How did she describe it? Twice.
Little. Oh, you little
gym. Yeah. You guys. Yeah,
you will sell events used to have that
bit whose joke is that was will sylvan
insane. I see in you your little
Mercedes with your little Rolex
taking me down. I'm not taking you
down. I'm just telling you, you know,
you're calm.
Tone is like when a pilot just goes
through turbulence and even he's scared,
but he doesn't want to scare you.
So he just speaks in that
I really hate when you reference yourself.
I really hate when you reference your own.
What am I supposed to do? I don't know.
It's who I am. I don't know.
But to reference your own
self is like so annoying.
And so
because I'm gonna Redo the garage.
I don't give a fuck.
Buh Buh, Buh, Buh better. Cause
you're bald. Fucking help me out.
No, you bought, pumped me up.
All right, let's get into the, uh, the
advertising for this week. First of all,
if you think you're going to be this,
I'm building a man's Jim.
This is going to be out there with like,
like fucking uh, Ooh. You had a baby girl.
Fucking risk weights. Your pink
fucking getting shaped girl waits.
It's not going to be that.
Yeah,
it's like itching to be the band.
That's crazy.
You gave her her allergy pills.
No, I actually forgot to. Did you really?
Can you come over to the mic so people
don't have to lean forward into their
dashboard?
Is it driving here?
People can hear it. You're the only
one who screams into the microphone.
Like completely defeating the
purpose of why a microphone exists.
I'm the only one who was screaming into
a microphone. No, but all right then
anyway. Oh yeah. So what I found,
what I want here is a rogue fitness.
Gee,
it would be nice if rogue fitness would
trade some equipments if for some free
advertising.
The WHO said that?
Our ml three w fold back while Mont Rack.
Say it again.
The rogue r m l three w fold back
wall mount rack made in the USA.
This is what's great.
It can fold back into the wall.
So if you have a small garage like me
that's built for a fucking, you know,
1928 model t Ford.
If there was one,
some gear heads we urge suitable
to continue in 1927. I don't care.
I don't make them. Um, what's great is
it has a pull up bar on it. It's got,
you can, you can move the
thing up and you can do squats.
Nobody does their legs
from my generation's all
about the upper body weight
doing today. Chairs to buy the, I can
try. Yeah, we got to do your legs, dude.
I walk around all the time.
Why?
Why do certain guys have like these
little chicken legs and these huge upper
bodies? What is that about? Is that
like that's a deliberate style,
like they're doing that on purpose?
No.
What it is is when you walk up to the
sink and you flex in the mirror you have
from your waist down is below the vanity.
So you can't see out of
proportion you are. But yeah,
and plus legs. It's not sexy.
It's not fun. It's hard.
It's work every, any.
Do you go to any fucking gym in the world?
If you want to go bench press,
if there's two people in there,
there's only gonna be two benches and
they're both going to be occupied.
That's all guys do. Every guy,
there's a zillion exercises,
but every guy goes over the bench press.
What are you putting up? A little bullet.
25. I'll be full. Good Times,
right? But all that other shit.
There's very few people that actually,
when you go to the gym have like a
proportion by the ladies are all about the
squats and everything because that's your,
that's your problem areas.
It's the biggest part of
your body as the legs. Yeah.
And actually if you build up your thighs,
you build that.
That's the biggest muscle in
allegedly burns enough fat.
And I could get rid of my see
belly here. See belly, good belly.
I was trying to be a gentleman.
Nothing.
Oh. Freckled cod belly shots.
You're caught nothing. Yeah,
you're dumb. I'm not dumb. There's a
lot of the CB this name. Huh? A pooch.
There's a lot of things.
I've got a baby bump.
I got it. I got it. Um,
there's a lot of too much
Gaba go. Oh yeah. Okay.
There's a lot of good
reviews for this thing. Yeah.
It got four stars or is that five?
Five stars. Five stars. Yeah.
Have you researched it? Um,
I'm going to handle all of it.
You tapped out this morning.
All right, fine. Fine, fine.
I'll let you handle it. You let me handle
it and I'll let you know how it is.
And when I walk around and I'm
shredded and I'm proportioned,
you're going to be like, you know
what? God Damn it. I was wrong.
Are you going to put it? And
I'll say I forgive you. Oh,
are you going to put up a mirror somewhere
so you can watch yourself while you
shred? See what? See what she's doing? You
a little Jimmy. You can put a mirror up.
I'll be right back. You're scared. You're
scared of what I'm going to become. Yeah.
All right. Let me read the
fucking advertising so I can
get on with the day here.
All right. Track are
smart cars, smart phones,
smart homes.
Technol technology has
made everything smart.
Balloons in your stuff's still make SMAD.
People feel really stupid.
Tracker making,
losing things.
A thing of the past track is a coin
size device that locates misplaced keys,
wallets, bags, computers, anything.
It's anything in seconds. Oh my
God, I fucking need one of these.
[inaudible] are you listening to this?
Just pet tracker to your smart phone
to attach it to anything and find its
precise location with the tap of a button.
It's that easy.
Lose your phone.
No problem.
Cliffy press the button on tracker
and your phone rings even when it's on
silent.
All right,
that's creepy how you hacking into my
phone here with over 1.5 million devices,
track as the largest crowd
gps network in the world.
So when you're lost item shows up
on a map, even if it's miles away,
never lose anything again with
tracker listeners to this show,
get a special discount of 40%
off your first track a device.
Go to the track at.com. Actually
it's t, r, a, C, k, e. R,
not a gauge to admin saying it
and enter the Promo Code Burr.
The hardest thing you'll ever
have to find is their website.
Go to tracker.com right now.
Enter the Promo code birth for 40% off.
Again,
that's tracker.com Promo Code Burr.
Never lose your shit again and buy shit.
I mean, not literally shit, but you stuff.
You still get pissed,
right? All right. Oh, zip
recruited.
As a business owner,
your company is only as good
as the people you hire. Well,
no shit posting jobs in one place.
While that isn't enough to
find quality candidates,
short staffing leaves time to post to
dozens of what short staffing leaves
little time to post to dozens
of job sites. Jesus Christ.
What is one to do position?
Zip Recruiter is the solution.
Well,
why don't you do that with the copy as
opposed to making me do all the fucking
leg work. Uh, you can post to 100
plus job sites with one single click.
Be instantly matched to candidates
from over 6 million resumes.
Plus Watch brand new candidates
roll into ZipRecruiter's,
easy to use interface
within 24 hours with zip,
Kroger,
it's been used by over 400,000 businesses.
Um,
today you can try ZipRecruiter for free.
Go to ziprecruiter.com/burr that sip
recruiter.com/ [inaudible] one more time.
Ziprecruiter hike.
Yeah,
ziprecruiter.com/ [inaudible] um,
one time we get to use it for free.
Well that's perfect. If you're looking for
someone to fucking, uh, you know Jesus.
40 minutes. I'm only supposed to
do a half hour here. I'm, I'm,
I'm working overtime and I'm on
salary. Alright. Have a great weekend.
You con and I'll talk to you on Monday.
Here's some more music from
Andrew Feminists and he's the one,
he's the reason why I know who about
mute math and I'm very excited.
I'm going to take the lovely near there.
I'll see you guys in the crowd. Huh?
Did I miss most of the podcasts?
Yeah,
unless you want to do a little
bonus time here. How about you cleo?
You want to do some bonus time?
Glio Nate kiss.
Hello Buddy. Get down.
Go lay down. Clean up.
Go on. Yes. Step right on it. Yep.
Step right on it. There you go.
Get over on your bed.
Get over there. Go on. Go
on. Lay Down about the,
Huh?
I talked about the Oscars the last
time. What did you talk about? I,
I was talking to how
white people fucking
crushed it again this year.
Oh, I mean, I don't really have, are
you allowed to be proud as a white male,
heterosexual and your faces other people?
Sure.
Uh, I don't, I actually don't have
anything else to contribute to stuff.
You don't have anything else
to contribute? I wrapped
up the podcast dead. Sorry.
I know I got all excited and
I realized I got nothing. No,
I thought I talked Chris Rock's
monologue was fucking tremendous.
I thought he had dressed in, I thought
it was, we was well balanced in the end.
He's like, yeah, we're just looking
for an opportunity. He can't,
he can't get mad at that.
You know,
it is funny watching adults wanting to
win a trophy belt. That is funny to me.
Cry. Um, anyway,
to be nominated for an Oscar that wouldn't
you? What's that? What have you liked?
Just crush it in a movie.
And there was talk of like at the studio
and stuff of you being nominated and
they wanted you to do a campaign and all
that kind of stuff that I would like to
be the guy that everybody says
should've got nominated and then didn't.
So then everybody feels bad for you,
but you don't have to campaign or go to
the shelf. That's the sweet spot in here.
Okay, that makes sense. Yeah.
You don't wanna be the guy that gets
fucking nominated and then you've got to
sit there with the camera on your
face as the guy with the fucking good.
What's that? What's that fucking kettle?
Kettle drum. Right. Like the Timpani.
It's just like, they're not going
to give it to me. Look at me.
I'm a balding fractal. Fuck. Right.
And then they give it to
the guy with the square jar.
Then he goes up there and
I sit there going, oh gosh,
such a low word of goals.
We're killing this. Um,
was funny fucking 12 minutes ago,
the first 58 times we did it. Yeah.
That's what I would like to be.
All right.
You want to be the guy that people said
get fucked over because then people feel
like you're still there.
You like the underground band?
Yeah. Yeah. Keep pulling
your eyebrows up. Like,
I haven't figured out
this fucking business.
I have all these dudes who get nominated.
The next thing you know they're fucking
doing crest commercials and they sit in
court side on the fucking game and then
people get annoyed because they start
seeing and when they shouldn't be
seeing them and then you're just fucking
everywhere and it's just like,
there's a hole in the ozone layer.
Hey Guy from this fucking movie.
What do you think about who I fit?
The constituents and you.
It's like,
why am I listening to this guy from the
reboot of Brady bunch talking about what
we should do in Afghanistan? And then
you jumped the shark and you're done.
You want to be the guy that people
are going like, he got fucked man,
that movie so much fucking better,
but blah, blah blah, blah, blah. Yeah,
you wanna you wanna beat chest
underneath it so people know who you are.
So they still show up to see
your Dick and shit jokes,
but you're not overly exposed.
I like your philosophy,
not the, I, there's nothing else
that I agree with. You what I,
I seriously do.
I'm not joking.
You've probably said that like three
times in the 12 years that I've known.
You said what? I agree
with you. I agree with two.
I have nothing to add. Yeah,
but I don't like it. Okay.
This is like when Vince Vaughn was on
Jimmy Fallon and knew Jimmy was trying to
get in his head when they were
going to play a, what's in the box?
The best fucking bets they call
what's in the box? What's in the bar?
I got to go a lie. I don't
know the liars box. Yeah,
dude, that was a clinic. That was a clinic
that Vince Vaughn put on there. Alright,
I'm a, I'm out of time here, right?
Enjoy the rest of the podcasts.
I'll talk to you on Monday.
[inaudible]
all right, here's the sexuality
situation. Everybody. Um, hey bill,
I need your advice on
something. Uh, this is a nut.
This is not about a breakup
dating are gold diggers,
but I think your advice could help me,
could help me out on an
extremely awkward position.
I'm 19 and I'm home from college for this.
I'm a,
I've been home for about a month
and I live in North Carolina,
but go to college in Arizona.
Dude,
good move Arizona with all
those fucking whores out there.
Come into class and like bikini tops
and you're out there with the acute and
cute southern drawl. How much asks
are you getting? Well, let's find out.
Shall We? Okay. While
I was away at college,
I have opened up to new ideas such
as politics, politics, religion,
and about my sexuality and my bias at,
and I am bisexual.
At the beginning of summer,
I started hanging out with my
old friends from high school,
one of which was gays. We
had messed around in high
school, but nothing serious.
What does that mean?
You flicked his balls a little bit.
Sorry. The fucking joke is there. I'm
going to do it. All right. Come on.
Take it like a man like everybody else.
Okay. Everybody gets trashed on this.
Here we go.
So this summer he and I were hanging
out at my house and nobody was home.
We started and we started to drinking.
Oh Gee. She's playing some music.
Why Mca?
And he started to smoke some weed man.
Then after about two hours,
we decided to do the dirty Jesus Christ.
Okay. Here we go. Slugging away through
here. Halfway through US getting it on.
My mom walks into the room
and catches us in the act.
Wow. Now talk about the needle
going off the fucking record.
She started yelling at me, swatting
me with the mail she had just gotten,
I'm surprised she didn't turn the hose on.
You kick my friend out of the house.
Then banned him from ever coming over
again and started screaming about the
Bible and a bunch of religious shit.
By the way,
this all happened when I was in a,
in a panic trying to get some
clothes. Oh my God, Dude.
What a way to come out.
Only thing was missing was a giant
neon. I'm gay. Sign hanging over your,
wow. That's a fucking
situation there, Huh.
Ever since then,
my mom and dad had been forcing me to
go to a few religious nutjobs that is
supposed to convert me from bisexual
to heterosexual. That's hilarious.
You know like you going to convert
a truck from two wheel drive,
the four wheel drive,
like it's that fucking easy.
This is a huge pain in
the ass because one,
there are churches on every
corner in North Carolina and two,
I don't want to change. So you
shouldn't, dude, you can't.
You are who you fucking are and they're
going to have to accept it. Also,
my parents had been treating me
differently now and it's really weird and
awkward every time we talk.
So I guess my question is how do I
deal with this through this is might be
outside the mother realm of my
lack of extra expertise here.
Do I tell them that I don't want to go
to some religious fat fuck who was a
Jesus Freak and whose stomach
is as long as his vowels?
Oh,
you got that southern draw.
You can't be suck in data.
Um,
or should I just pretend to be
straight until the end of summer,
then go back to living the life
I want to live at college. Also.
How do I keep saying with people telling
me that I am living my life wrong and
that God is judging me? I hope
that wasn't too sad, dude.
It's a fucking epic story. Thank you for
sharing. Sharon it here. Um, all right.
This is a deal to you.
You need new friends.
You need to keep the friends that accept
you for who you are and the ones who
aren't. You just got to phase
them out. Your parents were,
your parents will come around,
you know,
they get to come around cause
you're, you're their son.
All right? Stereotypically,
probably your mom before
your dad or whatever, but I
don't know, maybe they will.
Maybe they won't. But what the
fuck are you going to do? You know,
you are who you are. You've got to
go be who you're going to be. And uh,
as far as the tough it out for the
summer, that that's up, that's up to you.
That's up to you. If you're
going to keep going back. I mean,
if I was going to keep going
back to some shit that I wanted,
didn't want to go to,
I would just,
I would have fun with it.
I would just act like a fucking moron
and I would keep acting like I was almost
cured. And then at the last second
be like, but don't you think
John Travolta's cute?
Oh, no, no. Sorry. Sorry.
I'm just fuck with the guy who just have
a good time. If he can't get out of it,
if you don't want to, you
know, fight, you know,
if you don't want to be like Hitler and
try and fight on three fronts and ended
up in a fucking bunker, uh,
maybe just start with the,
get some new fucking friends. Uh,
that's it, dude. That's brutal, man.
That's brutal. But, uh,
you'll get through it.
You'll get through it and you'll find some
fucking people, you know? I don't know.
It's weird. In a weird way. Everybody
does that beyond that shit. You know,
as a comedian, I never fit in
anywhere. Everywhere I went,
like when I fucking had jobs and they
would be sitting there and I had my little
Michael J. Fox fucking suit
and tie on like thinking that,
that this is what I was going to do.
And everybody was going in for some
fucking meeting. I'd never gave a fuck.
And I never,
I just felt,
always felt like an outsider until
the day I walked into a comedy club.
And I basically found people who were
the same kind of weird that I was.
So they didn't seem weird to me.
A bit of middle of the Comedians
were all out of our fucking minds.
So that's what you have
to do in a gay way.
You just got to go find some heterosexuals
who were accepting of you and go get
some gay friends and uh,
you know,
you're going to have a great life and
you're going to have abs until you're 60,
evidently.
Cause that's how it works with gay people.
Fuck up
video. You are, and that's it. All right,
there you go.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
MMM.
[inaudible]
all right, sisters a
through c. Here we go.
Tired of giving advice to guys with
psycho suicidal girlfriends or people with
STDs? Well, I got something a
bit lighter, a few here. Uh,
kind of like the cores lite version
of your typical advice. Thank you.
And is perfect for the middle of the
summer. Like kick my feedback on this one.
So I know this lady who
I've been friends with uh,
for awhile now and banged one time,
she's the oldest of three sisters,
so we all call her sister a about two
years I made out with sister be in a club,
not my initiative. Um, and ended up
having sex with her the same night.
Jesus Christ. Dude, I
went out with her. Do,
do they have like that thing on the back
of their SUV where they have the stick
figures of the entire family and
you just slowly keep axing them out
in the family.
Doesn't understand if somebody's trying
to kill my daughters now I'm just trying
to fuck all of them, sir. Well,
that's a relief. All right.
Um, anyways, I went out
with her for awhile. Oh,
this is sister B.
And it was surprisingly not awkward
when we were hanging out all together,
even though everyone knew the situation.
Jesus Christ,
what southern state are you in, sir? Um,
I'll go fuck yourself people
down south. That was funny. No,
I'm some months later sister
be left me for one of her,
one of my friends and got
over it quickly enough bone.
You got over it quickly enough.
And nowadays I'm still in contact with
sister a and B since I'm not the kind of
guy that holds a grudge for that
kind of stuff. Well there you go.
It's very immature,
which means you really didn't give
a fuck about either one of them.
So why are you going to be all upset?
You know,
like you own their pussy once you fucking,
I hate when, I hate when guys do that.
Anyways,
recently senses to see,
started talking to me more
frequently after talking for a bit.
She said she could pose for me since
I'm a painter and she's a model and a 10
all the fucking way I might
add, oh, you fucking creep.
You fucking creep.
So she was attend the whole time.
So basically you're in a holding pattern
banging her oldest sisters waiting
until this girl was of age so he could
fucking painter Jesus Christ. I got I,
you know, I might have to
stand up and applaud this one.
This guy has taken it to another level.
This is a fucking epic situation here.
So you can see. Here's my question.
Does that proposition mean anything?
Do you need my advice?
I need advice from you. How do you
fuck every girl in the same family?
Jesus Christ. This is
like, you know, Long.
There's been an expense since has been
a triple crown winner in horse racing.
The last time someone
won the Kentucky Derby,
the Preakness and the breeders' Cup.
Is that what it is or is that a
soccer match? I don't fucking know.
I don't own a fucking horse since the
late seventies I would guarantee that it's
been since the late seventies since
somebody has booze bank three.
I think a lot can do two in one family,
but to get all fucking three,
two,
three,
two is a respectable three is it?
No,
it's beyond respectable. Two. Three. Okay.
Everybody knows three is in
the sporting world too. That,
that's a fucking dynasty.
Okay.
You just put yourself in there
with fucking Bill Russell.
You put yourself in there with,
with, with the fucking, uh,
Magic Johnson Lakers. You know,
I wouldn't say the Colby Lakers.
You know when you go out and you get
Phil Jackson and fucking shack that,
that's that new ship that the kids
like. I don't like that shit. Um,
either way, dude, you're
talking fucking dynasty. Wait,
magic never won three in a row,
but he had the Celtics to fuck with
and they went three out of four years.
Give me a fucking break. Um, so
here's Michael Jordan. There we go.
So here's my question. Does that
proposition mean anything? Is it a trap?
Should I try to bang her?
Should I try and bang her too and get a
third strike or keep my dick in my pants
and avoid a potential shit storm?
And if yes,
do you have any tips,
special tips on this special situation?
All my friends are telling me to do so,
but I thought I'd ask them.
We'll refine mine like yourselves
before I did a move. Dude,
you're looking at me like, dude,
you're beyond me right now. Okay.
This is like Bull Durham. I'm, I'm fucking
Kevin Costner. Um, I'm, I'm a lifer.
Okay.
You're,
you're going up to the show hidden brand
new balls every fucking day. I will.
You tell me. Okay. I never banked
to girls in one fucking family.
You know,
I was psyched if I was able to tag a
couple of friends and we were all hanging
out at a bar one night and you get that
feeling like I fucked both of you and
you both knew it and you both
loved it. I hope. Please,
please tell me you liked it.
Did you like it was I okay? Um,
dude, I think you gotta do
it. You gotta do it. You know,
you, you've been above board the whole
time. Sister [inaudible] sister be,
they all fucking knew everything right
now I understand this is a little
delicate. Okay. He's trying to snip the
last wire here. This is the kid sister is,
is it going to blow up in your
fucking face? Uh, it's worth it, dude.
It's worth it. It's worth losing a
couple of limbs and you nose on this one.
You got to do it to fuck. You know, dude,
what the fuck she says to you? I,
yeah,
you're a painter all let me take my
clothes off and get paid my fucking Twat.
That's not art too. That's
foreplay. Give me a fucking break.
It'd be one thing if you're
in a classroom of people,
it's just you and she's
standing there naked. Dude.
That's like one of the two.
Have they ever done that porn senate?
That scenario in a porno Jesus Christ,
you might've found a new angle
to. That's phenomenal. That is fucking
phenomenal, dude. You gotta do it.
You got to do with the John Elway.
We're tired when he only got one.
He came back for another,
right?
You got to do it to w
two.
That's like when Bush
fucking the first Bush.
He stopped and he didn't get to sit down.
You got to go all the way on this one,
man.
All right?
You gotta be like Marlon Brando in fucking
apocalypse now. You just, you just,
you just the fact you left the program,
all right?
And
I don't care how mad
these girls get to do.
You are at the precipice of
becoming an absolute fucking legend
Ledge who, who can, who, who's
gonna be able to top that dude?
There are celebrities who've had orgies
that had five on ones and all that type
of Shit, okay? But I guarantee you,
they never fucked three fucking girls
in the same family when they weren't
famous, not famous. You're doing
this shit with the gift of Gab.
Whatever the fuck you doing do you
do this? You got to write a book.
You got to write a book that's for,
you know,
that's used to collection of the most
amazing pussy getting stories ever that
you can somehow confirm,
all right?
And it has to be none of that bullshit.
The second you get famous, he get money.
That doesn't count, all right?
That's garbage time, okay?
They put the fucking second team in
there and you just fucking Titone layups.
That's bullshit.
I'm talking about just regular dudes.
You talk yourself into it through
the year, you're a fucking legend.
You gotta do it. All right.
There's my halftime speech.
I'm going to quote Joe Barton.
Nick quoting John Madden today is going
to be the greatest day of your life,
but only if you win.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
the way I think it's time.
I think we're about 17 minutes in.
I think it's about time. I patted
myself on the back. How bout that?
Download speed last week.
Huh? How about that?
I didn't hear any complaining. You know,
hundreds and hundreds of people bitch,
Moan and fuck.
Woo.
Right? So I finally fixed the
Goddamn problem and what do I get?
I get like five tweets going,
hey, I really appreciate it.
You know what happened in the rest of you?
Because you went on to
bitch about something else.
You don't like the photo on
my fucking page. You know,
you have to stop and thinking about,
you know,
maybe finding out what you're
really upset about Jesus Christ.
Could I use that advice?
Huh? Um, all right,
let's talk about something in the
news. Shall we, you know, I think they,
they should have to fucking sing the news
the way they do in the Catholic church.
You know,
there was a guy who got attacked
by two monkeys in South Africa.
He decided he was going to go down
there and try to rehabilitate some
chimpanzees that had been abused and
they turn around and drag them for two
kilometers and kicked the shit out of him.
What a dumb fuck.
Why would you fly across the world
to get your fucking ass kicked?
Did you guys hear about
the student South Africa,
Texas student attacked by chimp improves.
Thank God he improves this poor
fucking bastard. He's a ranger, right?
He loves animals.
This is the thing about animal lovers.
You got to realize that once you go past
a certain level of domestic animal and
you start getting into the wild,
no matter how much you love them,
they're not going to love you back.
Wild animals are like that. Dick,
you shouldn't have gone out with,
you know that person who cheated on you,
that person who just doesn't have your
back. Wild animals do not have your back.
You dog has your back,
you cat borderline.
Cats kind of have that creepy vibe that
if shit went bad, they decide what the,
the intruder, you know what I mean? Fish.
They just don't have any fucking say.
They're like a Stepford wife, you know?
That's why dogs are the best. They,
it's they truly fucking love you.
My dog fucking loves me,
will be on a walk and all of
a sudden she just look up me.
It's almost like she's smiling. You
know how fucking warped, why sound?
She's probably just panting and it looks
like she's smiling and he's probably
going like, why does he have
this fucking rope around my neck?
This doesn't make any sense to me.
If I really wanted to,
I could rip his fucking face off,
but in my world,
I'm so in love with my dog and look,
she's smiling,
but that's not bad when you just have a
dog. I think people who fucking, you know,
fuck with animals for awhile, wild
animals, they start thinking like, oh,
look at the Cheetah. Oh, she's play
a Gig and all of a sudden grow off.
This fucking launches itself that you
all right.
I believe that we came from monkeys.
I believe that we came from the apes.
I believe something else. So there's
three in a row in this sound smooth.
Um, but I by no means think that, uh,
that those fucking things like us,
I don't give a shit if I teach at sign
language and the chimps sitting at going
in sign language. Hey, I think you're
a cool guy there. Freckled face count.
You know that there's no fucking way I'm
ever going on the other side of the God
damn cage.
This poor bastard was on the other,
he was on the other side of the cage.
He just got too close.
That's how fucking insane a
wild animal is. Chimpanzees,
they say have the strength of six,
six men.
This dude got attacked by two chimps
that would be like getting attacked by a
flash mob. Okay. 12 fucking people.
They just grabbed this motherfucker by
his ankles. They reached underneath.
I mean, I don't what kind of bullshit cage
they had was like a compound, you know?
So they put up that, that,
that cheap wire shit,
when you don't want to rabbit to come
in and eat your lettuce right in your
garden. Like they put that
shit up. So this fucking guy
is sitting there, you know,
as they go doing that shit and he's like,
what are you guys join the show
me where you're telling me right?
And he's trying to sign to him. You
guys want to play Frisbee, right?
And they sitting there talking to
each other going just two more inches,
two more inches. Look at this dumb mother
fucker and wants to play Frisbee. Right?
They reach underneath,
grab them by his fucking ankles.
Strength. The 12 men, they fucking pull
them right underneath that goddamn thing.
Like when you go to Quiznos and they
stick your sub right through that poor
excuse for a fucking a brick oven
yanked fucker right underneath.
Oh my God. And then they dragged them
for like another fucking two kilometers,
however fucking far that is. I
don't know. In my world. That's a,
what's that about? A mile and a quarter.
Cause I know like 40 kilometers,
like 60 kilometers is like 40
miles an hour. Who gives a fuck?
They dragged this son of a bitch basically
through the length of every football
stadium in the NFL and I can guarantee
you it wasn't the nice turf that those
guys play on.
This was the natural habitat.
Like I can't imagine
the vice grip strength,
those, those fucking things, man, they'll
rip your foot off the rip your balls off,
the rip your face off the rip it off.
Like you open a fucking Goddamn thing,
a yogurt goddamn ice cream
when you just take the lid off,
they do that to your face. What the fuck
are you doing near these goddamn things?
You know
Jesus fucking Christ.
I would have to tranquilize had guns and
I would be wearing one of those fucking,
you know those suits you wear when you
think you're going to get bitten by a
shark, that chain link shit,
there's no fucking way.
There's no way fucking catcher's
mask welded to my face.
I'm not going anywhere in here.
And not only that,
these aren't just regular fucking chimps
that have been swinging around eating
bananas occasionally eating
another monkey alive, right?
This isn't that shit.
These are ones that were abused.
They were already fucked with.
Okay.
And having adopted a
fucking abused dog and
the Goddamn Skitzo Shit that that
thing does, I can't fucking imagine
a goddamn schizophrenia fucking
ate two of them straight to 12 God,
they are men and you're going to walk
near the cage trying to sign, hey,
how about the weather frank or
whatever she fucking human name.
You gave him your at you already
a fuck and God bless you,
your heart's in the right place.
Fortunately this kid doesn't seem
like he had any damage like that,
but like this dude was so in shock,
like they were finally able to just
like stitch him up and stabilize him and
evidently he's not in critical
condition and it doesn't seem like,
it seems like he still has his balls,
his feet and his face,
which is incredible.
But they say, you know,
he has bite marks and
a and fractures plural.
Oh my God,
just treating you like a fucking rag doll.
That is the most horrifying
shit in the world to meet.
Nature is the most horrifying
shit I would rather have.
Oh, let's see. You know
what? The human equivalent,
someone has to come into my
house with a fucking chainsaw.
I can deal with the Goddamn,
I could deal with the machete.
All right. I could deal with that.
Chainsaws that, that's hardcore.
I could fuck a machete. I could deal
with, I think I could fucking do the, the,
the sugar ray Leonard,
you know,
stick my face out and then pull it back
when he took a swing and then fucking
try to take both of your legs out.
Yeah.
Ah, only hardcore boxing fans
got that one. Um, but the,
I mean if you were in a room with the
chimp and that thing goes fucking ape shit
, no pun intended. That thing is on
the floor. It's up on the ceiling.
It's across the room.
It's like,
it's like a comet and you're sitting
there dealing with human speed
do.
That's why we got the brains that we have.
This why was so much smarter. We have
to be because we're so fucking slow.
You know what I mean?
You ever see the white guy who gets
dunked on in those highlight films?
You know that fucking guy that they bring
off the bench when the teams either up
by 30 or down by 30 that guy,
that's what we are in nature.
Even the fucking athletic humans yet you
know when nowhere near just take like a
how fast a fucking snake is
a fucking pit viper, viper,
righteous, nothing. Fucking, you don't
eat your bit and that thing has left,
left the fucking building
before you even did,
before that signal from
your fucking leg going, hey,
we just got bit by a Goddamn pit
viper even reaches your brain.
That snake is already leaving
and then you go and then the real is,
and as the realization that
you got bit hits you, you are,
you're already collapsing.
Why the fuck would you go out there?
You know, I don't know. We
had to be that fucking smart.
I can't imagine that the Goddamn
fear back in the fucking day,
you're walking around with a bunch
of Goddamn neanderthals and whatever.
Niana talls I guess I suppose to say I
sit in the Andrew Thall my entire life,
but it's Neanderthal, I guess. And
what else was it? There was two tribes.
One of them died off.
There was the enter talls and then
there was the fucking crow magnums.
And I forget what the fuck we are.
One of them, one and the other ones,
the other one of them's was a little
bit smarter and the other ones were a
little dumber and dumber ones died off.
All right.
And some people have a little bit of
that Crow Magnum or Neanderthal in them,
you know, because you know
that people they fuck right.
It's gotta be the dumbest
education of podcasts you've,
you'll ever gonna fucking here.
Yeah.
I just totally lost my train of thought.
What the fuck was I talking about? Oh,
Niana toss.
Right.
So I can't imagine just
fucking walking around.
Did you ever see that shit when they did
that whole thing on chrome Madigan's in
neanderthals,
like one of them was like fucking slower,
like the fucking white dude in the NBA
and one of them was a little bit quicker,
a little bit smarter.
So they fucking did this shit where like
when they would show him like taking
down some prehistoric bison, like the
fucking little smarter ones, you know,
they could fucking, you know that
that Shit, they could slip a punch,
they could throw a goddamn spear.
They could do,
they could do it from a fucking distance.
Like this fucking jackass. He wasn't,
he was too close to the Goddamn cage.
The fucking Chromatin is whatever.
The dumber ones they would like
fucking day would just brute strength.
They would fucking run and try to tackle
the thing and someone would, you know,
separate their shoulder,
a break and elbow and there's
nobody around a set that shit.
Every step in your fucking non-existence
shoes, your big stupid prehistoric foot.
It's just shoving that pain shoot through
your body. I edged. Can't imagine,
I can't imagine sitting there looking
out of a cave in everything is that much
faster than me and I don't have a
fucking door. I don't have a gun.
He just must be just
sitting here like any,
can't really communicate to the other
person because language hasn't been
developed yet, so you just haven't
that. What the fuck? Look on your face.
That was probably one of the
first phrases invented like,
are you shitting me or the killer?
Can you fucking believe this?
I Dunno, but God bless that
dude. You're an animal lover.
I totally know where you're coming from,
but for the love of fucking God,
those things are not your friends.
Okay?
I Dunno. Start p nine dx in and stay away
from that fucking cage. Jesus Christ.
Can you imagine that
I am getting dragged away by
two fucking abused chimps.
Then you know God damn well he saw
that fucking Oprah won't episode.
That woman came on with no face. I know
he was fucking thinking of that shit.
I hate those motherfuckers. You
know what? As I like gorillas.
I hate chimpanzees and I
hate those little monkeys,
the little motherfuckers
that throw their shit at you.
I can't stand those fuckers.
And I hate chimpanzees.
I always hated those motherfuckers. I
didn't know why. And now I know why.
That was my inner fucking whatever
the fuck caveman telling me.
Get the fuck out. Go
back to the cave. Stupid.
I don't trust them. I don't, I
don't trust those fucking things.
You have to go to the
zoo and you just fucking,
you just your eyes meet with like a lion.
Just that fucking look on
their face when they, they,
they should.
I've said this before,
it's like the same look like when
a hooker looks at you like it's,
it's the real deal.
You know,
this isn't some fucking bullshit.
Flirting, playing hard to get,
get a couple of drinks out
of you. It's, yeah, you got
20 bucks, I will suck a dick.
What? You know, lions got
that same look on their face.
Like, yeah, if you know,
if you weren't in that fucking armored
vehicle or on the other side of this,
yeah. If I was hungry, I would eat you.
And uh, no matter how much you screened,
I wouldn't give a shit.
It'll actually excite me more to rip
your fucking head off. There's no way.
There's no way. There's no fucking way.
That's why I watch all those animals.
Thanks, man. I'm fascinated, and I, and I,
I appreciate all those people that put
themselves in harm's way because there's
no other way to really gauge how strong
an animal is until you see it slap
around a human being.
Like,
I can't watch too fucking grizzly bears
wrestle and slap each other. They're,
they're in the same weight class.
You know what I mean?
If I see him bitch slap a human being,
then I'm and watched the guys heads spin
around a couple of, I was like, wow.
All right, I get that. I can now
gauge that. Let's like, yeah, like,
like a kilometers versus miles.
All right.
I think we killed that subject.
MMM.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].